hi everyone i'm zoe saldana i'm standing
here on behalf of our marvel community
my colleagues my actors my crew my
producers my directors and we are
sending a message of support and courage
to all those families that are being
affected by hurricane harvey and in the
city of houston and we just want to send
a message out to everyone that whatever
you can do to help please go online go
to the Red Cross org go to any ABC
network and donate anything that you can
from $1 $5 a box with a canned goods
toilet paper towels anything you can to
support those families that are being
affected today we are very fortunate
right now we get to go to work and we
get to go home to our families and there
are many people right now that don't
have a home are losing family members
and don't have work so please whatever
we can do to help we all stand as one
when one city is under water we are all
under water so to everyone being
affected by hurricane Harvey we are here
we're going to try to help you